Welcome back everyone this is the way this will
be my full star wars book of boba fett episode
5 video you could also think of it as like an
early episode for the mandalorian season 3 because
mando is finally back there were so many
easter eggs and so much lore that they
cover in this episode it was probably one of my
favorite episodes of any star wars series ever
if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes there's
a bunch of big stuff coming up we have the star
wars obi-wan kenobi episodes and obviously the
mandalorian season 3 episodes that'll be coming
careful for spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet we'll be talking about everything
i'll just start at the beginning and go through
scene by scene talking about easter eggs wtf
moments and all the teasers that they use to
set up the mandalorian season 3. starting with the
episode title chapter 5 return of the mandalorian
you could also think of it as a sly wink at the
return of the jedi title because so much of the
book of boba fett has been referencing return
of the jedi easter eggs there's also a lot of
references to the jedi the mandalorian jedi tarre
vizsla who created the darksaber as well as grogu
who's in the middle of his jedi training and we
know that grogu is going to be coming back in
next week's episode too which i'll explain how
they set that up at the end of the episode too
but first i gotta pay a visit to a little
friend he's got a very tiny very little side
quest that he has to perform before he helps
boba fett out with his pike syndicate problem
cannot wait to see grogu in that tiny little
mandalorian baskar armor that he had made for him
this truly is the way but the actual opening
scene is of the mandalorian going to an alien meat
factory on the killing floor to pick up his latest
bounty named caba baez this introduction scene is
meant to be a parallel for his introduction in the
mandalorian season one episode one it almost plays
out the exact same way with a lot of the same
dialogue too as he enters the frame they play the
same mandalorian theme music cue that they played
at the end of the book of boba fett episode 4.
we all knew he'd be coming back it was just a
question of which episode it was going to be in
the alien that he's after here is actually being
played by one of the stunt actors from the obi-wan
kenobi series we'll probably get the trailer for
that after the book of boba fett finale so we'll
get a lot more obi-wan kenobi footage pretty soon
he's still got his mandalorian spear which they
wind up melting down to make grogu's best scar
armor later in the episode and the whole idea
here is that he's doing this bounty just as a way
to help find his old mandalorian covert the place
where the armorer went after the mandalorian
season one finale because we didn't see her at
all during the mandalorian season too but we
knew she was still alive they give him a very
captain america winter soldier elevator scene
moment when he offers to let everyone get out
who doesn't want to get their ass beat or killed
before we get started does anyone want to get out
and when cabba baez says let's discuss our
options it's also meant to be a reference to
his line to the mythrol in episode one horatio
sans character where he's like i can bring you in
warm or i can bring you in cold i can get
you more credits i can bring you in warm
or i can bring you in cold i can bring you in
warm or i can bring you in cold it's literally
the exact same line there's a lot of moments
like that during this episode where he repeats
dialogue either from earlier star wars movies
like he makes a lot of phantom menace references
later when they go back to tatooine or lines
of dialogue that he said previously during
the mandalorian season 1 and season 2 just to
connect things back to the mandalorian series plot
love the way he whips out the darksaber and cuts
through all these aliens like their hot butter
they also use this scene to show you how he needs
a lot of training with the darksaber like he
is just bad fighting with it you can't blame him
because he's never fought with a lightsaber before
also they introduce a bunch of new mythology and
lore for the darksaber that they did not do during
the clone wars series when they introduced it for
the first time that was actually probably one of
the coolest parts of the episode like all the new
backstory and lore that they write into the canon
and most of that stuff comes from dave filoni
because he's one of the people who created the
darksaber in the first place back during the clone
wars many many years ago with george lucas there
are really only a couple people in the galaxy that
could train him to fight better with the darksaber
like ahsoka luke skywalker who are still around
but also by coincidence the armorer who does show
up right after this the little bd-1 droid is
also a huge easter egg for jedi fallen order
this is the same droid that cal kestis had during
that game it's even featured in a lot of the art
for those of you that are hoping that calcustas
shows up in the future of the mandalorian series
he's another one of the jedi that will still be
alive in present day when this is happening after
the original trilogy love the full ring station
reveal too you can tell that they spent most of
their budget on these last couple of episodes
like oh this is where all the money went that's
why things seem so simple the first couple of
episodes after he returns the bounty and finds
out where to find his covert he uses his visor to
find the ultraviolet symbols and follow the trail
these are all mandalorian symbols to help guide
him there and the final symbol is the head of
the mythosaur which was the symbol that they use
for their covert during mandalorian season one
is the same symbol that boba fett has on his arm i
talked about that during my previous book of boba
fett episode video where he first gets the rancor
so i'll link that below in the description if you
want to learn more about why he has the mythosaur
on his arm they finally bring the armorer back
we didn't see her during mandalorian season two
and we find out that john favreau's past vizsla
character also survived the heavy infantryman
they made it seem like everybody else died so
i'm glad they brought him back but because jon
favreau kind of calls the shots with dave filoni
and what happens within this mandalorian universe
of tv shows in this part of the star wars timeline
i do think it's funny that he did not kill himself
off like i'm not going to kill myself off i'm the
boss they also need him for all this darksaber
mythology that the armorer introduces to the
cannon and all the easter eggs for the clone
wars episodes with pre-vizila in the darksaber
there are so many easter eggs within easter eggs
within easter eggs they get super meta with all
this darksaber mythology and i completely love
it this is probably one of my favorite parts of
the episode when paz vizsla says there are three
of them left i think he's also including mando in
that head count but i love the way they foreshadow
this battle for the darksaber when you see him
hold it up revealing why he got injured like what
did that to you and he holds it up paz vizsla kind
of freaks out underneath his helmet the whole
idea here is that paz vizsla is a descendant of
pre vizsla from the clone wars the former leader
of the death watch mandalorians which is where
their covert comes from i'll explain that in a
second too because there's a couple other lines
of dialogue that clarify where their special
sect of zealot mandalorians came from but dave
filoni and george lucas created the darksaber for
this specific pre-vizsla character when they were
doing this clone wars episode so that he would
be a threat to the jedi and he was voiced by
jon favreau so when he came back during the
mandalorian season one as this heavy infantryman
another member of that clan a descendant of his
it was just meant to be a cool callback to that
but also the canon states that the darksaber was
created by the first mandalorian in history to
ever become a jedi knight and he was named tarre
vizsla another one of paz vizsla here's ancestors
that's why later in the episode when he challenges
mando for the darksaber he says fate has brought
the darksaber back to my family's clan it was
forged by my ancestor founder of house business
paint has brought this blade back to my clan so
there's just a lot of really cool meta easter eggs
going on here with the darksaber the armor then
gives mando a bunch of lauren history behind the
darksaber itself she says the mandalorians have
existed for ten thousand years whereas the empire
only lasted for thirty that's a reference to the
original mandalorians when they first started to
expand their empire ten thousand years ago also
puts them firmly in the middle of the old republic
era but just to explain the timeline tarre
vizsla that original mandalorian jedi created the
darksaber about a thousand years ago the other
huge thing that they do in this episode is the
armor gives him this mandalorian prophecy about
the darksaber and is very much in the vein of game
of thrones and the prince who was promised azor
ahai the bringer of the dawn about what happens
if the darksaber is taken in combat the way it's
supposed to be earned and what happens if it's
not if it's stolen if it's not one in combat how
it will lead to the utter ruin of the mandalorian
people and they kind of throw boca tan crees
under the bus like katie sakhoff is probably
upset about this like oh man they really threw my
character under the bus here it's meant to set up
this cautionary tale of what happened with boca
tan crees during star wars the clone wars and
then star wars rebels she was gifted the darksaber
during star wars rebel she didn't win it in combat
and the armor is basically saying that it led to
the ruin of the mandalorian people the great purge
and they were scattered as the legend tells that's
why during the mandalorian season 2 finale boca
tan was so wary about taking the darksaber from
mando when he tried to give it to her she probably
also believes that she was partially responsible
for the great purge because she took the darksaber
instead of winning it through combat properly it
depends on whether or not you believe that kind
of superstition but they're basically pinning the
great purge on boca tan mando kind of recaps the
plot of mandalorian season two for both of them
because neither one of them were around for season
two he explains how he won the darksaber from
moff gideon in combat and also where he got the
best gar spear from from ahsoka he keeps calling
them the jedi like he doesn't say the name ahsoka
and he doesn't say the name luke skywalker he just
refers to them as the jedi and grogu's kind when
he talks about taking grogu back to his people i
don't know if i totally buy the armorers reasons
for wanting to melt down the best gar spear she
says it's dangerous for their people because it
can also pierce beskar armour but really i think
the reason they're doing this is to pay off the
grogu bhaskar armor that we'll probably see happen
during episode 6 next week so r.i.p to the beskar
spear the spear did nothing wrong but it's all
in service of a cooler payoff with grogu later
when the armor says bo katan lost her way like the
mantra says this is the way that's a reference to
the special hardcore customs that mando's covert
of death watch mandalorians follow never taking
their helmets off is just a really good example
of that bo katan told him during season 2 that
his group was a special sect of zealots so the
armorer is kind of throwing shade in boca tan
and all the other mandalorians that followed her
ways after the clone wars and star wars rebels
like there's a big question as to whose way is
the proper way then like i said the armor also
confirms that their sect were the death watch
mandalorians because she says that they were
cloistered on the moon concordia that was a moon
of the planet mandalore ruled over by pre vizsla
leader of the deathwatch mandalorians and the
death watch mandalorian symbol was all over the
armor of the ones who rescued mando as a child
then huge wtf scene they actually flashed back
to the great purge itself i'm surprised they paid
this off so soon like they show us the great purge
in this massive fleet of thai bombers come and
just slag the entire planet into pure glass that
was what mando was talking about when he told bo
katan that the surface of the planet mandalore had
turned into glass because the crust of the planet
had melted from all the destruction of the bombs
they call this the night of a thousand tears and
the armor is blaming it all on bo katan and the
other mandalorians who followed her that is one
sick burn right there she really hates boca tan
maybe we'll get to see the two of them face off
at some point if you didn't watch the clone wars
or star wars rebels the dome here is where
the mandalorians main city was on the planet
because the surface of the planet had already
been rendered uninhabitable by all the civil
wars the mandalorians fought thousands of years
ago so after the mandalorian civil wars ended
they all unified they moved under this giant
dome so when the tie bombers blow up the dome
just to give you a sense for the scale it would
be like if the entire north american continent
was living in a giant super city under a dome like
that's how big this is meant to be the droids here
that you see going full terminator walking through
the battlefield are the k2so models from rogue one
there's also a bunch of classic probe droids
around them scanning for targets and then mando
asks the armor to create grogu's best gar armor
and the reason why it looks like little tiny
links here is probably because it'd be some form
of chain mail something that will contour to his
body and be lightweight enough but this also kind
of makes you remember all the memes and the fan
art of grogo in actual mandalorian armor from
season one love the darksaber training montage
here on the catwalks is also very reminiscent of
luke skywalker's lightsaber fight with darth vader
in return of the jedi on the death star with
all the catwalks as is his fight later with the
past vizsla character lots of return of the jedi
callbacks because this is the book of boba fett
when she talks about him fighting against the
blade instead of his opponent the blade getting
heavier in his hand it's meant to be a metaphor
for mando accepting the full responsibility that
comes with the darksaber accepting the
mantle of leadership that comes with it
the thing that's distracting him clearly is grogu
that's why he said earlier he's worried about him
he even told her he wanted to go see him to know
that he was okay they also set that up at the end
of the episode too his little stopover before
he goes to help boba fett out with the pikes
then like i said they used the paz vizsla duel
for the darksaber as a way to pay off a ton more
clone wars easter eggs for pre vizsla now fate has
brought the darksaber back to my clan because it
used to belong to my ancestor before darth maul
killed him and took it from him you also notice
that when he takes it fermando like he picks it
up and tries to use it against mando it's heavy
in his hands as well he can't wield it because he
took it from mando he didn't win it in battle yet
then they finally pay off the big twist of
season two with him taking his helmet off
multiple times first to save grugu's life getting
the information on where to find mof gideon ship
and then again to take it off so that grogu could
see his face before saying goodbye and yes the
armor does kind of kick him out of the club so
to speak for admitting to it but not forever the
whole thing with him redeeming himself in the
living waters beneath the minds of mandalore
i think is meant to foreshadow the mandalorian
season 3 and beyond because that also connects
with bo katan's greater war with the empire and
grand admiral thrawn to try and retake the planet
mandalore for their people mando can travel to
the mandalore planet by the end of the mandalorian
season 3 and enter the waters they don't have to
defeat grand admiral thrawn for him to do that
but that's basically your next big mandalorian
season 3 teaser yes they do say the mines have
been destroyed by the empire but the living water
that he needs to walk in would still be flowing
beneath the planet's surface so it still exists
for him to walk in he just hasn't figured out
how he's going to get to the water itself but the
whole thing here him walking away is for the next
stretch of story he will technically not think of
himself as a mandalorian he won't call himself a
mandalorian the droids here that take his weapons
as he enters the transport ship are the star tours
droids the line about weapons being his religion
is also another line that he said during season
one the little rhodian kid reminds him of grogu
he also kind of folds the pouch of new mandalorian
armor for grogu into the shape of grogu's head
like you can see the shape of his giant two ears
here sticking out then the starliner travel name
drop i think is also meant to be a reference to
the real life disney starliner cruiser ship that
they just debuted the super expensive hotel that
you can actually go stay at he goes back to mos
eisley and reunites with pelly motto and all of
her droids from a new hope in the prequels this
is r5 the gonk droid and the treadwell droid from
a new hope in the pit droids from phantom menace
we've seen them in previous episodes before too
and there was a flashback easter egg for pele
motto in an earlier episode of the book of boba
fett and like i said that little tiny droid that
helps him repair the ship is the bd1 droid from
calcustus in jedi fallen order she references
all of his previous tatooine episodes slaying
dragons with season two episode one taking down
the crate dragon chasing bounties was fennec shand
in season one also foreshadowing fenix shan
showing up at the end of the episode to ask
him to help with boba fett and the ship that she
gives him as a replacement for the razor crest is
literally one of the naboo n1 starfighters from
phantom menace anakin skywalker's original ship
as a child she even references padme when she says
that they were commissioned by the queen of naboo
she references the galactic republic because
that's the period of history where the ship
came from before the imperial era but the father
that she mentions are the horse animals that
they ride for sport during the last jedi but
remember the last jedi takes place about 30
years after what's happening in the events of
this scene in the present day of the episode
the hyperspace docking ring is a callback
to obi-wan kenobi using the same type of
ship with a docking ring to travel to kamino chase
down young boba fett in jango fett to bring things
back around to boba fett because this is meant
to be his show even though this episode is kind
of like a mando season 3 episode inside the book
of boba fett they set up the big montage with the
jawa stealing all of the old parts for the ships
that they need they also used that to tie back in
with the whole pike syndicate plot for the finale
saying that the jawas are basically stealing parts
from the pike syndicate i did think it was a
little weird that pelimado dated to jabba but
when she says they're furry underneath their robes
they have never revealed canonically what jawas
actually look like under their robes but the
whole funny thing here with them suping the ship
up making it super fast with aftermarket parts
is basically giving him a version of space nos
to make a big fast and furious reference in the
reason why they sand off the yellow paint instead
of making it look exactly like it did during the
phantom menace in the prequel movies is because
if it looks silver like this it looks like a
different ship that they can sell as a different
toy like yes we know you all bought those phantom
menace toys back when it first came out many many
years ago but now you have to buy the new one
because it's a different version most of you
also probably detected the r2 reference here when
she says that she took out the r2 connector unit
in the back pod here the little pod because it's a
very grosgu sized pod so you have to imagine grogu
flying around with him in the back of this ship
then a bunch more star wars prequel references he
starts testing it out in the canyons just like the
pod races also he uses the dank ferric word again
that's kind of like star wars equivalent of the
f-bomb they say it all the time on all the shows
they also make a baker's canyon reference
because that's the place where he goes
it's a call back to a new hope the place where
luke skywalker would fly his t16 bullseye womp
rats which you actually see later this creature
is a womp rat that scurries away as he flies by
it's not impossible i used to bullseye womp rats
in my t-16 back home they're not much bigger than
two meters also you could think of this canyon run
as a reference to the old school star wars video
game rebel assault where you literally start the
game by flying tutorials in a t16 through beggar's
canyon i have not played that game in so long i
think that was a dos game he flies past the same
rodian child and then they bring back the new
republic x-wing pilots from mandalorian season
2 or at least one of them captain carson tiva
comes back and he makes a bunch of references
to the mandalorian season two but the other x-wing
pilot here is a huge easter egg that some of you
may have detected so this is actually the same
actor who was luke skywalker's double in the
mandalorian season two finale casting him was a
whole thing too because we had to work with sarah
finn and say hey look we want to find somebody who
physically resembles what mark looked like right
after turn the jedi they also use this x-wing
scene to show off what the ship can do and how can
fly under the radar at certain speeds all meant
to set up a big dog fight that he'll probably
have during the finale with the pyke syndicate
when it comes back to the hangar bay mando makes
another anakin skywalker phantom menace reference
when he says the ship was wizard well how was it
wizard this is so wizard and i'm sure you'll do it
this time it as predicted fennec shand shows up to
hire mando as muscle for boba fett who says that
he'll help for free but he's got to pay a visit
to a little friend which obviously is a big grogu
reference meaning we'll see grogu in next week's
episode episode 6. just like they used this week's
episode to give you a bunch of backstory on mando
and what he's been doing since the end of the
mandalorian season 2 they'll probably use next
week's episode with grogu to explain what he's
been doing with luke skywalker jedi training since
we last saw them during the mandalorian season 2
finale but if you spotted any other easter eggs in
the episode that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments there are
two more episodes left my full book of boba fett
episode 6 video will post next week just like
normal so make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here for my new marvel secret invasion first look
video and click here for all my book of boba fett
and mandalorian episode videos thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!